what if the world lost oxygen for five
seconds
five seconds may not sound like a whole
lot of time to be without oxygen most of
us can go at least 30 seconds without
taking a breath so it would happen too
fast for your body to even notice if you
happen to be relaxing at the beach at
the time expect a severe sunburn take
away the oxygen and the Earth would get
extremely hot planes would fall from the
sky and millions of cars would be
stopped in their tracks and while all
this is happening the Earth's crust
would completely crumble that's because
Earth's crust is made of 45 oxygen the
crust would crumble and continue to
crumble until there's nothing left so
have you ever asked yourself